Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
Je m’appelle Mirabelle Kajenjeri,
j’ai 23 ans
et je fais de la musique
depuis près de 20 ans,
ce qui revient à dire depuis toujours.
Je suis née à Kiev, en Ukraine.
Ma mère est d’origine ukrainienne
et mon père est d’origine burundaise.
Quoi de plus banal ?
Nous formions une petite famille modeste.
Mais aucun de mes proches
n’était vraiment musicien.
Cependant, mes deux parents ont côtoyé
dans leur adolescence
l’univers artistique propre
à leurs cultures,
à savoir : ma maman a pratiqué
la danse classique
et mon papa jouait du tambour
traditionnel du Burundi.
Si je vous raconte cela,
c’est pour en quelque sorte
introduire le sujet d’aujourd’hui
qui a été en même temps
le fil conducteur de ma vie :
la mixité.
Comme je le disais plus tôt, j’ai eu un
attrait quasi immédiat pour la musique.
Par la musique, j’entends le piano
et le violon,
car à 6 ans, j’ai voulu, en plus du piano,
apprendre le violon.
C'était comme ça et pas autrement.
Je me rends compte aujourd'hui que
dès mon enfance et tout au long de ma vie,
j’avais besoin de ces deux instruments
aux antipodes l’un de l’autre,
mais en même temps
tellement complémentaires.
En fait, c’est assez représentatif
de mes origines tellement diversifiées.
C’est ainsi que mon parcours
musical a été jalonné
de différentes expériences
passionnantes et édifiantes
dans l’apprentissage
de ces deux instruments.
Ce n’était pas une tâche facile que
de cumuler les deux à un haut niveau.
Je me suis heurtée
à des difficultés en tous genres,
mais cela ne m’a pas empêchée
d’obtenir mon diplôme de licence
dans les deux instruments
la même année,
à quelques jours d’intervalle.
(Applaudissements)
Merci ! merci !
Aujourd’hui, j’ai fait le choix
de me consacrer davantage au piano.
Mais les bienfaits de mes connaissances
violonistiques n’ont pas de prix.
Alors, à titre d’exemple, lorsque je
travaille dans une œuvre au piano
un passage chantant mélodique,
je m’appuie sur la sonorité
du violon que je connais si bien
et qui est l’essence même de la mélodie.
Je peux à tout moment prendre
mon violon dans les mains
et me laisser inspirer par sa sonorité.
En disant cela,
j’aimerais porter votre attention
non pas sur la technicité musicale,
mais plutôt sur ce que
l’un apporte à l’autre.
C'est cet aspect de la mixité
que je trouve intéressant.
En effet, l’un vit très bien sans l’autre,
mais lorsqu’il y a un échange,
c'est d'autant plus beau et créatif.
Il en est de même pour mes origines,
qui m’apportent des visions différentes
sur le monde et sur la culture de l’autre.
En tant que musicienne,
mais avant tout en tant que personne,
cette mixité ne peut qu’être
un atout et une richesse.
Et cela m’accompagne au quotidien,
à commencer par les différentes
langues que j’utilise pour m’exprimer,
et pour revenir à la musique,
les différents styles musicaux
qui font partie de moi.
Je me tiens aujourd’hui devant vous
pour représenter la culture, la musique,
la musique classique.
J’ai dans mon répertoire du Bach,
du Beethoven, du Chopin,
du Mozart, bien d’autres encore.
Je suis sûre que ces noms de grands
compositeurs vous évoquent quelque chose.
Très souvent, on associe la musique
classique à une autre génération,
celle du passé et de l'ancien.
On pense que cette musique a vécu
son temps et n’a plus rien à apporter.
Ce sont des préjugés
que je peux comprendre.
Mais pourtant,
à l’instant où je vous parle,
des milliers de jeunes musiciens,
comme moi, du monde entier
se prennent de passion
pour cette musique et cet univers.
En apportant cet exemple,
j’aimerais vous sensibiliser au fait
que nous ne devrions pas nous arrêter
à des idées préconçues
sur telle ou telle forme d’art
et, à plus grande échelle,
sur telle ou telle chose.
Certes, cela pourrait nous déplaire, ne
pas être notre truc, comme on dit souvent,
mais nous ne le saurons que
si nous faisons un pas dans la découverte.
C’est ainsi que j’aimerais vous encourager
à ne pas avoir peur de la différence,
mais à l’embrasser et expérimenter
ce qu’elle a à vous apporter.
Vous pourriez être surpris
de l’impact positif
que cela engendrerait
sur votre vision du monde.
À mon humble avis,
la mixité n’est qu’une force.
Mon parcours en est un témoignage
et j’espère de tout cœur vous avoir donné
envie d’aller plus loin vers l’autre.
Pour conclure, que diriez-vous
d’une petite échappée musicale ?
(Applaudissements)
J’ai préparé pour vous la troisième
ballade de Frédéric Chopin,
compositeur du 19e siècle.
Ce choix n’est pas du tout anodin,
car Frédéric Chopin incarne
lui aussi la mixité.
Il était franco-polonais.
Je vous souhaite donc d’être transportés
le temps de quelques minutes
et des milliers de notes
dans l’univers qui m’est si cher,
celui de la musique.
(Applaudissements)
(Piano : Ballade n°3 en la bémol majeur)
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)